So at this point, I should stop and talk a
little bit about the type of data that we'll be working
with, in a number of places in the rest of
this course. So I'm sure you're aware that Wikipedia, in addition
to the article text for many types of data, also
includes info box data. Now, info box data is essentially structure
data that complements the subject of the article. In this
case, this is an article for the city of Hyderabad and,
in addition to a description of the city
here and other interesting information about the city,
we have data in the form of, population,
land area in square kilometers, as well as a
number of other useful pieces of data about
this city. Now, Wikipedia has info boxes for a
lot of different types of data. People, animals,
automobiles and so on. An organization called DBpedia has
taken the info box data from Wikipedia and produced it as
a collection of data sets that we can download. Here's a
description of some of the data sets themselves and some of
the details about them. Now, in our case, we're going to
be working with the city's data set. This data is distributed
as a CSV file that we can download. It contains all
of the info box data for a particular snapshot in time
for all cities described on Wikipedia, for which there is info
box data. Now, in order to prepare this data as
CSV, the DBPedia folks had to do a little bit
of work in encoding it, to get certain types of
data values into individual cells. Let's take a look at
the city's data set. We're going to look here, in
Excel, because this data is so dense, we really do
need the added structure that the spreadsheet app provides. So
here's a row for Hyderabad. And, there are about 20,000
rows in this CSV file; so, lots of cities
are represented here. And, we can see that there are
lots of null cell values. This is coding in this
data set which indicates that there is no value supplied
for that particular piece of data. Now, something that's
also important to bear in mind is that while this
data is actually in pretty good shape, it's entirely human
generated. You can edit it by editing the Wikipedia page,
as usual. There is some of that data here. So
what this means of course, is that there's a lot of
dirty data here. Data that's going to need to be cleaned
up. So this data set provides a nice example of wrangling
data, because we're going to have to decode some of the
fields in order to get them into the form that we
want. We're going to be looking at transforming these lines of
data into JSON documents, and then, eventually, storing them into MongoDB.
Let's take a look at a couple of examples
of the task that we have ahead of us. Okay,
this is the postal code field, and we can see
that there are lots of different formats represented here. Something
else that's interesting about this data, is the way
they've encoded arrays. Some fields have multiple values stored within
them. Here's the utcOffset field. And in this case, we
can see that there are two values for the utcOffset
for this city and a couple of others here. There's two
different values that represent the utcOffset for when the city is on
Daylight Savings Time versus when it's not. And you can see that
we have some HTML entities represented here, and some Unicode characters, and
some other characters that we're going to need to a little
work with. So we've got our work cut out for us with
this data in terms of pulling it out of the CSV form,
parsing it into individuals fields, and cleaning up some of the problematic
data that's here. After that, then we'll take a look
at getting into MangoDB. So as you can see this
data set provides a nice opportunity for us to explore
things like auditing a data set, to see where the
problems lie. And then thinking about exactly what we should
do with fields like this and other structures that we're
going to find in this data set. And then finally,
we'll take a look at putting this data into MangoDB.